il va falloir composer ne pas trop
tomber dans la compromission mais
travailler sur des compromis donc c'est
le message que passera et vous avez deux
bornes et avec tout le suspense qui se
doit la parole à madame rachida dati qui
je le rappelle n'a toujours pas gagné
une élection encore à la dernière
élection je crois en trois choses
l'écoutent l'action et les résultats je
n'ai qu'une boussole
quand vous gagnerez une élection sur
votre nom surtout vous nous alerter
parce que nous les 1,7 pour cent on n'y
est pas abonnés voilà ça c'est votre
bilan nous devrons travailler
progressivement un peu plus longtemps
[Applaudissements]
il vous me parlez du discours de lire et
de bornes de trouver son discours
absolument remarquable elle a couvert
tout le champ des préoccupations mais en
fait je réclame une commission d'enquêté
pour savoir qui a écrit ce discours
autant peuplé de truites banalité c'est
même pas respectueux du parlement
voilà on en vient presque à regretter le
style enflammé de jean castex même temps
ça fait vingt ans dans perdu toutes les
élections c'est vraiment dommage se
rendre donc toutes les grandes
démocraties ont fait ça le premier
ministre se présente il fait un discours
de politique générale et puis il ya un
vote du parlement l'annoncé à dire que
gouverner va être le fait du prince ce
n'est pas acceptable et donc un principe
démocratique et qu'elle ne demande pas
le vote de confiance nous déposerons
donc une motion de défiance mais à ce
jeu politique toute la gauche n'a pas
envie de participer les socialistes qui
ont refusé d'intégrer la nuque et les
radicaux de gauche affiche un sourire
amer et bien cette gauche gras elles
existent elles existent à l'assemblée
nationale elle est aujourd'hui
minoritaire et nous ne voulons pas céder
aux finalement aux injonctions des
insoumis et nous ne voterons pas cette
motion de censure probablement oui elle
ne sera pas adoptée mais il est
important de marquer des actes la
démocratie c'est pas accessoire dans
notre pays et de même que l'opposition
ce n'est pas accessoire dans notre pays
puisque madame la première ministre vous
êtes aujourd'hui dans l'impossibilité de
solliciter un vote de confiance et j'ose
dire que vous avez bien fait car nous
n'avons aucune confiance dans votre
gouvernement
je préfère se met le col à l'est que ce
qui vous met mal à l'aise ça fait mal an
on servait pas ça va vous faire mal elle
ça va nous faire mal ça va faire très
très mal je le sais et dans l'avenir ça
va faire encore plus mal
excusez-moi j'ai quinze minutes enfin
j'ai fait un autre intervenant de jerry
dias et des bleus qui ne leur viendra
pas moi merci non ça ne va pas c'est
l'intransigeance leurs énormes sans
paroles ou l'irrespect plus tôt dans la
journée certains élus de la nuque
organise même un mariage fictif entre
emmanuel macron
et marine le pen
le rassemblement national s'est retiré
de la course à la présidence de
l'assemblée permettant à madame prendre
privés d'accéder à son trône le
lendemain des députés de mort en
anglais ça fait plus de cinq ans que des
centaines de français sont détenus dans
ce camp syrien 51 sont arrivés sur le
sol français hier trente cinq mineurs et
16 mères âgées de 22 à 39 ans des
milliers d'américains célèbrent leur
fête nationale avec des feux d'artifice
et chaque année il y à des incidents
heureusement ici le bébé au premier rang
a été mis à l'abri parmi ces femmes et
midi koenig parties en syrie en 2012
elle est soupçonnée d'avoir agi comme
recruteuse notamment pour l'état
islamique
[Applaudissements]
l'année prochaine peut-être faudra-t-il
éviter de laisser un carton rempli de
feu d'artifice à proximité